a couple of years ago i had a bunch of
people
i got i got a bunch of messages like
telling me about autism some asking like
asking if i have it and
and once out of nowhere i didn't know
like why
like i just like i i i it was like i
just saw a bunch of messages at once
that were about autism i didn't know why
but um i think like i fee i it was right
after i did an appearance
on uh uh regis uh not regis uh kelly
ripa
and and at the time chris pratt was the
we didn't we did press okay
[Laughter]
we were doing press and we went on the
morning show with kelly ripa chris pratt
was the guest so you know chris pratt
yeah you know him gnome i feel like you
might have for some reason i met he
invited me to be in a film that he did
okay yeah yeah that was oh yeah that was
yeah cause i think we were gonna do the
the cruise again
and you had to do a movie was that oh
yeah that's right yeah that's right i
want to get you back because you were so
sweet on the first cruise oh thanks i
had booked it up completely and you were
like i'll just come on like i'm hanging
everything and yeah it was so sweet man
and then i wanted to you know i was
trying to get but yeah anyway he's on
and he's in this movie the magnificent
seven that remake of that western movie
at the time it was just came out as a
blockbuster there was like an ensemble
cast of a-list morgan freeman's in it oh
no it was denzel denzel's in it right so
the night before i had cotton really
really really drunk
i don't normally do that but like i just
i don't remember what i was wedding a
wedding tonight oh yeah so i show up i i
am hungover with the shakes
okay and you have to get arrived at like
6 50 in the morning and for the morning
show right so i get there and i'm
trembling man
and i don't know what to do and i'm like
i can't go on i said can i please can
you please find an office for me to lay
down in and they did because we weren't
going to be on for an hour they took me
to someone's office i laid down on a
couch in someone's office just shaking
so
i'm watching the the show on the tv and
it's in the feed right and
then like so so at the beginning they
give away a prize have you ever watched
regis and kathy lee when you were little
but i know about it so every day they
take a phone or they just take a phone
call and someone in the audience and if
the person in the audience answers
correctly like them and the phone person
wins like a trip
or like something big every morning
every day oh wow so they're doing this
trip right so they asked the lady a
question and uh it's easy but she gets
it wrong right and then chris pratt goes
adam will give you the trip anyway it
was a vacation and then on air he goes
what what oh i can't do that because
it's like law it's all
game show right right so then he goes oh
i can't and on air he's like oh i don't
know what to do and everyone's like oh
and then he goes uh
i'll give you the trip i'll just buy it
i'll give it to you and everyone's like
ah they went nuts right
and uh it was like so nice and then
kelly's like i won't do that to you like
me and you are going to split the trip
you are still going and the audience
goes crazy right
then denzel washington comes out next
and he's in the movie magnificent
magnificent seven with him and he comes
out and
the first thing he says was uh he goes i
just i was watching on the feed he goes
uh what happened how much was the trip
and chris pratt goes like 5700 and he
goes
three ways i'm gonna go three ways with
you on the trip so everyone goes nuts
right so i'm laying that you know how
you always need stories on these things
yeah they want you to have stories so
i'm laying there like half sick and i'm
like all right i got an idea so i'm i i
have this thing i'm going to do in my
head and then i'm like i want to do
something else these things never go
well morning shows they like rush you
through you never really get to really
make jokes you know so i was like [ __ ]
it so i had our assistant go to the
store get a pack of haines t-shirts
white hanes undershirts and a marker
and i wrote i oh in my own handwriting i
wrote magnificent seven on on the
detains t-shirt and i put that on
except for fun i spelt it wrong i wrote
magnificant savon uh-huh s-e-v-a-n and
magnificat so maybe we can't savon so i
was like i'll just i'll go out there
and i'll go out there and what i'll do
is they'll immediately see my shirt and
be like oh what is that you know and
i'll be like oh i just thought that you
and denzel needed help promoting the
movie
obviously they don't need help right i'm
like yeah so i just wanted to support
and help you guys any way i can i know
you need to help and then i thought they
would pick on how i misspelled it it'll
be a nice joke so i put on the shirt
so we're behind the thing we're ready to
go out there i'm wearing this hanes
t-shirt that has marker on that says
magnificant savannah and they call us
out and we go on people are cheering i'm
waving right and we go to sit down and
right before we sit down the audience
starts clapping and i go i just won't
let everybody here know just off the top
i'm not going four ways on the trip with
the woman
right i thought i would get a laugh
but they took me seriously it just
bombed and then kelly goes no no it's
okay we're covering it it's okay and i
was like well that was a joke yo then i
sat down to the interview and nobody
mentioned the shirt dude
nobody mentioned the shirt so i
and then after that i just started
getting autistic messages because i just
went
like i went on like i came out i was
like i'm not paying i'm not paying for
the for the trip and then i sat down and
my shirt was handmade and misspelled and
nobody mentioned it and then that
everyone was like yo like they're just
sending me links
on autism
people like hey can you come speak at
our school
oh dude
it's online too it's online like you can
pull it up
damn bro that's bananas man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one